[Music]
i build models sometimes with weird
materials and i've always found aviation
to just be
really kind of magical just because
airplanes are engineering marvels
and i wanted to marry that with the
unconventional building technique
this great big story was made possible
by geico believe it geico could save you
15 or more on car insurance
for my
day job i work in i.t and management but
i've just always been creatively minded
i've always been drawn to those kinds of
projects
i've been making
things since i
could figure out what tape and string
were
i was super young i probably drove my
parents crazy i'm best known for the
paper airplane models that i make
what i use to build the models is manila
folder glue an exacto and a straight
edge essentially
it's hard to know exactly how many
folders i've gone through but i would
say it's in the hundreds for this
project and there's a lot of scrap left
over
[Music]
i kept it to a minimal set of materials
just because i like the challenge of
building something from only one thing
and having to figure out how to make
that serve many purposes
[Music]
the model began on a much less detailed
scale but i did over time realize that i
could start building in more
articulating functions more details in
the interior and inside there are
tissues in the bathroom there are lights
on the seats nothing actually moves in
the cabin but all the detail is there
i've always just found the triple seven
to be a really elegant nicely
proportioned plane and so it was partly
an issue of aesthetics i've always just
been a fan of that particular model
i studied pictures online some technical
drawings and actually create my own
plans and there's just no guide for how
to do that so i'm basically learning
along the way
it's simultaneously kind of freeing and
also really frustrating not to have
plans i can really take it in any
direction but you have to be incredibly
inventive about how you solve problems
because it really hasn't been done
a lot of people probably think that my
end game was absolute perfection with a
model but in fact it was more just about
the process of making it
it's the thought of the completed
product that inspires me and just being
able to solve such a complex problem
it's just what i derive a lot of
satisfaction from
you